[Music]
shut up
hello and welcome to the final episode
of trash taste ever in 2022 oh you got
me ah guys in the first time I got you
there I got you today I don't think
anyone would have fell for that yeah all
right all right welcome to trash days
I'm your host for today gaunts and uh
with me as you saw the boys
because it's the end of the year guys
you know it's the end of the year it's
the start of a new year do you get sad
at the end of the year I always get
excited
I get that's not like an AI prompt
I'm
excited
I am happy it's like there's an AI
generator
but it sounds like a human way of asking
it what was the human way okay why would
you ask are you sad by the way I'm happy
okay what is the mindset no my mind says
I always get excited at the end of the
year because it's like it's it's like
turning over a new Leaf
why would he be sad well God was saying
this is like oh it's the end of the year
I'm a bit sad and it's like sounding sad
I'm like oh do you get sad
um I don't get sad I get I get like
we're talking about sad guys I don't
know I need to make sure I'm doing okay
guys I'm doing okay I'm not sad by the
way we should just get AI to write this
[ __ ] party oh my God we did an
episode where an entire trash days
we should do an episode and then we
should 100 do this uh well every
everything we talk about is an AI prompt
sure yeah okay that's that's an
interesting first episode first episode
of 2023. this trash taste episode has
been AI generated
so Joey what do you think of chicken
feet how do you feel about chicken feet
it is gelatinous and delicious
nutritious yeah so you were saying what
what emotions do you feel at the end of
the year what emotions do I feel uh yeah
a little bit of excitement I think
everyone's always excited for the new
year to Starbucks like I don't know
something about
something about going into a new year
right the January February month it
doesn't you're still like you're still
like mourning the past year it always
feels like you know I was trying to find
a word to use but it doesn't feel like
it doesn't feel like the new year has
like it feels like the previous year
version two yeah yeah yeah yeah you
still like mentally you're still like
turning over to the new year yeah I
guess because there's no big like kind
of like Earth doesn't have this built-in
program that is like it is now reset
yeah it's softer yeah it's like just
kind of like well next day in it yeah
it's yeah it's that it's that period
where like especially when you're in
school and you had to like you know
write the the date on you know your
paper or whatever yeah it's always just
like okay January 2nd 2020 oh wait I'm
in 2023 now
you know everyone had it everyone went
through that [ __ ] yeah I didn't find a
Nemo come out in 2008 or something I
feel so old just I just thought about
that
for some reason whenever I think about
when Finding Nemo was released it makes
me feel old
because I can remember watching and
getting excited
yeah that's like [ __ ] amazing I had
traumatic nightmares of with [ __ ]
Bruce the shark dude he's hype that's
like that's like if he was the opposite
dude do you ever just have this thing
where there's like certain shows or
movies or something else that in your
mind feel new even though they're like
[ __ ] 10 years old now or something
like that oh like like of a recent
memory yeah like like for me like I have
like so many anime that for me like feel
new it came out two years ago yeah
gorilla gone feels like came out two
years ago it was like 15 or something
years old I also feel that with like
League champions as well I don't know if
you feel this as well
yeah to me like a champion like for
example like azir feels new to me yeah
you know and it's just and it's just
like I I know he's [ __ ] decades old
now or something like that and it's
totally relate yeah you can relate right
Joey
stay relatable [ __ ] Hanzo means
I know my references I don't know I
think um looking back at the year
um it's I don't really get sad to answer
your question I'm just going to put you
off topic yeah sort of and really get
sad I normally try to remember the
highlights and if something bad did
happen it's like okay well am I kind of
past that now yeah because I feel like
especially of recently you know like
with the whole [ __ ] Duma culture
especially among like you know just like
[ __ ] people oh you know this year was
horrible and I'm like okay yeah no the
world is definitely [ __ ] but I feel like
now it's like kind of the thing to just
be like [ __ ] pessimistic and negative
about [ __ ] even if it's like not
necessarily something that you should be
pessimistic about like you know it's
like having a forward like thinking or
being positive about something is like
seen as uncool now I mean I get it I I
get it I mean I don't know that I'm
British I get it because I feel like
we're doing that [ __ ] for thousands of
years I will admit that like there's
never been a time uh in in like the past
like you know 40 50 60 years
um where it was
um as [ __ ] to be a young person like
like there was it's never been like in
terms of if you're just the average not
like talking about ours or whatever but
like if you were like an average person
who was like 15 16 yeah yeah it's not
looking great like a lot of modern
developed countries you know uh it's
getting a lot more top heavy with age
and then there's a lot of social issues
going on yes of course jobs don't pay as
much as say rent and buying a house is
like impossible so oh no I understand
where a lot of the the anxiety comes
from in terms of being pessimistic and
it's hard to be like hey no dude just be
positive and it's like well yeah a lot
of people saying that their lives are
going good
um so I understand why they'd want to be
pessimistic but I do admit though that
there is definitely the feels like it's
almost like a competition about who can
be more yeah who can suffer more than me
but and you know and then they're saying
this from like their like [ __ ]
MacBook and yeah yeah like
it was such a [ __ ] year uh tweeted from
iPhone 14.
I get it in a sense but yes no I get it
I get it too but you know it's I think
it's also important to I think it's a
balance right it's like you know you
don't want to be like taking the [ __ ]
happy pills and being like Oh yeah you
know just ignore everything bad that
happened and just link to next year but
you know I think it's important to be
like okay yeah some [ __ ] things happen
this year some good things happen this
year like you just kind of weigh it out
to see like you know which ones you want
to forget about which ones are important
which ones you want to learn it just
seems like no matter what furries are
always winning they just always they
somehow always have money another good
year review thing everything always goes
well from Billy I don't know why they
always have money
worries no matter what always seem to
have disposable income even when it
could be like the greatest of great
depressions and they'll still be
commissioning artists at premium rates
for porn I don't have oh how do they do
this I feel that way towards me I know
how to budget
two dollars on food five dollars on like
electricity you got like 100 and Bill
and two thousand dollars on like a furry
suit or whatever it's like
you have ten dollars to spend and then
it'll be like one dollar unlike this
thing yeah you know that the Twitter
thing yeah it's always like ten thousand
points
sorry go ahead go ahead you know at
least they're happy yeah I mean like to
me like I I really like I really like
December as a month because there's a
lot of exciting things happening
Christmas click forward too and I I love
that period before the new year so where
it's just it's just Anarchy nobody knows
what's open what's going on are you
working no are you working no everyone's
not working you get to like catch up
with family and stuff like that you get
to hang out go on holidays and then like
January hits and you're like when is the
next time that something big is
happening and you look and you you look
at January and look at February and
normally the earliest something biggest
plan is like March you know and that's
when that's when to me like like I like
December but like the January February
month I like the hangover after like the
cool December month you know you need
that though I think it's important to
have a month where there's not that much
going on yeah especially you know like
our jobs as well we're always doing so
much I think it's good to have those
kind of months where everyone's kind of
resetting and getting ready and getting
plans ready
um because I've already made a lot of
plans for like March April next year but
I've made nothing for like January on
purpose yeah because nobody remembers
what happens in their January and
February you like okay because it's like
what did we do in this January February
we went skiing we had a little boy ski
trip oh [ __ ] that was that that was this
year wasn't it that was this year yeah
it feels like 10 years ago God I just
realized I skied for the first time this
year yeah [ __ ] twice you've been twice
this year I've been three times three
times yeah yeah
oh my God this guy I'm just I I
completely like just forgot that this is
this is my first this is my first year
of skiing that I ever experienced yeah
I'm gonna be completely out of touch by
the next because
he talked about like being excited for
the new year and like you know this
whole Duma culture I feel like that's
just been exasperated by
the corona years you know like two
pandemic years
three pandemic years if you think about
it because it started in early 2020
right yeah yeah exactly so we basically
had like three pandemic years where it's
just like you know we looked at the year
and we thought couldn't get any worse
than this it got worse and they were
like couldn't get any worse than this
still remain the same and you're like
okay okay this is the Year this is going
to be the year it did feel like it was
never going to end yeah and then finally
2022 here and I feel like this was the
year that we were kind of waiting for
you know this was the year where it kind
of feels like you're getting a bit of
normalcy is that a word yeah back in
your life and stuff like that and I feel
like you know it's this was a good year
I I would say this was just
from my personal perspective I would say
this was a good year but also you know
talking to a lot of my friends or
something like that it was better than
2021
most people had a better year this year
yeah you know people want to see their
family people got to you know spend more
time I don't remember what I did in
2021. it's like that year is a blur for
me yeah it's like I remember doing a
shitload of trash taste and like maybe
seeing my family once and then that was
it because I didn't leave Japan at all
yeah at least you guys left you died in
2021 yeah we did and that was [ __ ]
that was terrible yeah yeah I had to go
back in the thought the fact that I I
completely wiped out of my memory but I
stayed in that quarantine yeah yeah like
for like three days right I was like if
you'd asked me to do that now I'd be
like no but I think I was so desperate
to see my friends and family yeah I was
like [ __ ] it fine I'll I'll stay in the
stupid hotel for three days yeah I
didn't want to uh obviously no yes no no
no no one's been one night in an apple
Hotel let alone let alone three all
right it's the last resort just I was
just thinking of like the stress you let
you go through just to go through just
to go insane like the easiest kind of
travel routes you know yeah that was
that was it was like that was so
traveling was so stressful back then
yeah and now it's still not it wasn't
nearly as it's still not as seamless
yeah um you know if anyone's coming into
Japan or planning a trip Japan you'll
know you have to you know even though
it's not a big deal the whole uh vaccine
passport and doing the whole stupid app
thing like it literally doesn't matter
because everyone's just turning up
anyway and then they just are like okay
just yeah just do this showship action
it doesn't matter but it's like Japan is
like projecting stress onto you yeah to
get in and it's making you feel like do
you have these 17 pieces of essential
paperwork it's like uh like right now
I'm flying to America and I get emails
like every [ __ ] five minutes yeah the
airline Caribbean like do you have all
your documents in order and it's like I
just need to I don't even like just I
just need the vaccine passport that's
literally it would stop spamming me this
[ __ ] yeah because it feels like life is
moving fast whilst again you know like I
I because it was so weird right because
I remember moving to my new house right
and I remember signing at like a
two-year contract because I was like I
remember the first place that we moved
to the two years felt like an eternity
oh right holy [ __ ] because we always
used to like live really close together
and those two years felt like it lasted
forever so I I yeah so I moved to this
new place thinking two years that's
gonna be forever because it felt like
forever in my last place right and like
my two-year contract is like renewing
within like six seven months now yeah
and I'm like what the [ __ ] I've barely
stayed at my place what
yeah and and I already got to think
about like renewing the contract and all
and all this type of stuff I was like
this
like the time even though like I spent
almost the same amount of time in this
new place as I have in the old place it
doesn't feel proportional at all you
know we're also just getting older I
think it's true like that whole thing of
like you know when you were a kid I
remember like you know your your parents
or your grandma being like Oh man it's
already been a year Iris still remember
10 years ago and as a kid you're like
what the [ __ ] you talking about like
this year has been like a quarter of my
life yeah like it's been so [ __ ] long
but now it's like I was like Finding
Nemo was yesterday right yeah yeah I was
like yeah right the 90s were 10 years
ago right and then you just like nope
it's not it's 20 years ago and it's like
oh [ __ ] because like it's probably a
mixture of the pandemic and also the
fact that we are like you know gradually
getting older that like this year just
[ __ ] like went by like that for me
because like just thinking like you know
some some of these like episodes that we
were doing with some of the LA guests
was like six months ago yeah I'm just
like that was not six months ago [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] that wasn't actually no
that feels like five years ago because
we've done so much [ __ ] in between ax
was six months ago holy [ __ ] isn't that
[ __ ] yeah even when I do nothing
though I find that time goes by even
faster because then I because then I I
look back and I realize oh what did I do
I didn't do that much and then it feels
like instead of like I have all these
individual events to remember it's like
I just have this small Gap that's like
squished where I was like I was playing
TFT yeah
okay keep me in the tour I'm like that's
just one month of TFT wow that was I
also happened to perform everything
what's the saying again it's like there
are some weeks where decades happen but
there are some decades where weeks
happen or something yeah what was that
from I forgot what it was
serious I've heard that a bunch oh no
[ __ ] some leader said that I think it
might have been a bad thing
no it was like a [ __ ] Russian leader
Google it Google it yeah not a bad
leader I think I also [ __ ] it up I
said it the other way around
there are some decades where weeks
happen but there are some weeks where
decades happen yeah is that is the
correct time yeah who said it who said
that
I don't know
yeah yeah
when he said Vladimir I was sweating
yeah every time I hear your name is
Vladimir I'm like are you a cool one
yeah no but like no but I I feel like
that saying is especially true for
especially for this year for me because
it's just like you think back to it like
you know even just the stuff that we do
for trash taste was just like insane you
know especially compared to the first
two years because we [ __ ] weren't
doing anything during the first two
years yeah yeah here in the office just
talking about exactly this year of trash
tastes felt weird because instead of
filming consistently like on a week-week
basis it feels like we've we had like
we've had like one or two months of like
intense intense intense trash Chase
filming yeah I see these boys every day
and then we'll have just have a month of
just like traveling and doing other
things and then we come back and we're
like [ __ ] we need to catch up again yeah
film 10 episodes in like the grand old
star boy yeah I mean uh I know the
audience sometimes complains like I
backlogged too much and it's like well
it's obviously it's not ideal and I
think we we don't like it sometimes we
have to record so many episodes back to
back but it's either like maybe you get
an episode that isn't as exciting as the
previous one but you get one week yeah I
mean we prioritize that like you get an
episode every single week no matter
where you are we pride ourselves in the
fact that we're like 130 episodes in and
we still haven't missed a week no no we
still haven't missed the week and it's
all been in person like yeah like set
out to be so we've had to like intensely
schedule around that with how busy this
year has been so yeah highlights guys
what's uh what's been your year the tour
was a good one right yeah
eventually you guys will see some of
that yeah eventually
or getting it edited right now
um obviously married man oh yeah [ __ ]
you're the man
wow thanks for remembering guys thanks
for remembering it feels like a year ago
that was this year yes Don loved getting
married so much you did it three times
obviously yeah gone getting married what
else is there I mean yeah like the fact
that I had diamond on TFT oh yeah
same same time same tier of Happiness
right there yeah yeah
um I mean you know we've again as we
were saying like we did that trip to uh
the states and we finally filmed trash
tanks outside with us guests as well
yeah that run was really good I felt
like that that was really fun and
Incredibly satisfying getting to do so
much cool stuff with other creators yeah
I I don't know I don't think any of us
had really gotten anything like that
where we kind of just met a bunch of
cool people and filmed a bunch of stuff
and
for me it felt like if thinking back on
the year the Year for me started in
April because like the earliest big
thing I can remember to be like
like the earliest big thing I can
remember is like looking because
normally we plan out our entire year
right so I remember looking at the
schedule
um and I remember looking at April and
April was when we had planned to film
our road trip special across Japan oh
yeah then I was looking at the road trip
special and I was just like when am I
gonna have a free week I don't think I'm
gonna have a free week between April and
November and I pretty much did not you
know I think I've had a free week at all
this year yeah now that I'm thinking
about it remember I did have a free week
I I was like Chris let's go cycle across
Hokkaido so you won't agree so I was
like
I mean I do that though I see like a
full three days I'm like man I should I
should uh I should do something yeah
fill it up with something yeah even
though like it's it's for the most part
A lot of the times it's completely
unnecessary no I mean like I just I'm
always itching to do something I feel
like oh man I you know I think uh it's a
better it's a good habit because like
sometimes it's like we work so hard and
you know and I think we rarely get to
sometimes take a moment and enjoy
ourselves but that's the thing right
it's like I'm gonna go travel let's do
something yeah yeah but that's the thing
it's like every time I say like even
like three days just like back to back
to back free yeah my head there's like
The Logical side of me that's like oh I
should probably fill this up with
something to do you know some work
related things and then the child side
of me is like I start a new jrpg right
now probably finish it and then The
Logical side at the adult side of me
always [ __ ] wins I'm like yeah
another week gone just like that I love
playing album ring so much this year it
was so fun it was so good it was so good
yeah I like dead ass don't remember some
months like just some months are just
like March I don't remember what the
[ __ ] we did March we were filming ahead
to March was just all filming yeah right
that's probably why I don't remember it
you know what let's look at the calendar
I'm glad I have my calendar uh and I
literally put everything in my calendar
now it's my my God if it's not in the
calendar I will forget it let's go let's
go let's go
oh my god oh man yeah no this was a lot
of filming for me yeah okay now we
filmed the road oh wait this is April
hold on uh March is what are we doing
March let's see oh we did the charity
stream in March oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that was
this year yeah yeah oh my God and then
we also went to a bunch of conventions
as well yeah yeah the first time I went
to Trio as a trio for the first time and
it was also like our first post pandemic
convention which is insane and it was an
experience oh yeah that we were not
prepared for I don't think no I I really
really really liked cons a lot and then
after this I was kind of like I think I
like cons a little less yeah I think it
was like I think uh like I think we
mentioned this as well like we're just
like yeah I think um we said this in
previous episode where I was like yeah
it's kind of up to the point now where
it's like a little too big yeah not to
be like I'm such a big [ __ ] deal it's
like can't you know can't really enjoy
them the way I used to yeah yeah it's
like going around it's gotten to the
point where you just can't enjoy
conventions for conventions
unfortunately
um which which makes me sad because I do
love walking the artist alley and stuff
like that I do love just walking around
the conventions taking it out again
maybe going to a random panel you know I
remember doing that and unfortunately
that just wasn't possible for us at any
convention that we went to this year
yeah
um you know maybe maybe I'll fall off
maybe I'll maybe we'll like L plus ratio
sometime soon yeah right put our careers
on the line so we can walk the artist
Sally again it seems like a train
I'm like man there's just been a i I'd
say it's been a pretty great year yeah
it's been it's been a pretty great year
absolutely and I feel like we've
definitely this year has been like such
a big focus on trash taste even more
than previous years even though we like
focus on our personal channels and stuff
previous years as well I feel like this
year with the conventions with the tour
with the specials we've done and
everything like that it's just this year
I saw these boys faces alone even more
than before so thank
God we had thank God I actually you like
we were actually really good [ __ ]
friends yeah because this year was the
real test from that you know yeah this
is like the three year limit you know
that every couple goes through it's like
if we go after the three year mark I
think we're pretty cool yeah yeah we had
a lot of questions on tour and people
asked us they're like man you guys you
guys have any like arguments falling out
I'm like wow I don't know not really
kind of kind of pretty good at knowing
how to like hang out yeah I feel like
we've been friends so long now it's like
we just get each other yeah I know that
we don't let it devolve into an argument
I mean it was even even like I was
surprised at how like weird not not how
weird but how
uneventful just like the the bus
experience was in terms like when I say
uneventful just like like in a negative
sense yeah it was just like nothing
really happened there was no tension no
drama no like not even like slight
annoyances you know it was just a very
pleasant experience and people were just
like yo still the T what happened on
tour it's going to see and I'm just like
who's hating who yeah yeah and I'm just
like nothing really happened I I feel
bad because it always sounds like a
cop-out to be like no we just got along
really well and everyone's like no there
must be something there must be
something
yeah and I'm just like I'm I'm like
reaching when I'm like Connor would not
stop playing TFT and it annoyed the
marker he flooded his room because of
TFT actually which was an actual problem
there's no bearing on you guys yeah yeah
yeah
um yeah like because like we got along
with the staff uh all the shows went
really well everything would chill I
think we're just chill guys I think I
think we we don't expect sorry sorry I'm
so chill guys if like we're on the same
bus I don't feel the need that I need
God's attention or need to like talk to
Joey all the time it's kind of like oh
if we got something to talk about it
with us yeah yeah have you had that
question with like personal friends and
stuff or you're just like oh what
happened on tour and you're like oh
nothing much yeah then they go no what
really no nothing nothing I'm like no
really nothing my own sister asked me
that she was like so did you guys like
fight on the bus I'm like what the [ __ ]
no
no
well I always go on tour with people I
would go and get in a fight with stop
boxing yeah just just punch the [ __ ] out
of each other yeah yeah no I mean like
yeah I think the the tour especially
like everything we wanted to go well
went well and yeah you know as boring as
it sounds for for the drama channels we
literally nothing happened this episode
is sponsored by gamer Subs boys I have a
news update sugar is bad for you but
Joey I like my sugar so much how can I
get my sweetness if I don't have sugar
I'll tell you right now gone if you need
a clean energy drink with no crashes no
sugar and tastes amazing drink Gamers
that exists it is zero calorie Energy
Formula and keto and diabetic friendly
and idiot friendly that's why I drink it
and if you don't start drinking game of
Subs we will come to your house and feed
you gamer Subs directly like a bird
they have so many weird flavors would
you like us to make a flavor
also they've got these waifu cups in
which you guys probably probably see us
drinking from every single episode and
every waifu cup comes with a free sample
of gamer Subs zero calorie energy drink
and a waifu sticker to boot this is our
waifu cup which you can't get anymore
because you missed out on it guys so
every time they release one that's your
only chance to get it so don't miss out
guys gamer services are a lot more cool
projects they're looking towards next
year and anyone who hasn't checked out
gamer Subs yet should go check them out
so get yourself a waifu cup using the
link down below with code trash taste
this episode is sponsored by Factor guys
I know you love your cooking right I do
how often do you cook all the time ever
yeah because what I would say if I
cooked all the time but I don't well if
you're lazy like Connor and have never
cooked a meal in your life well factor
is the thing for you factor shops preps
cooks and delivers to your door so you
can enjoy Chef crafted dietitian
approved meals during the holidays minus
the hassle plus with 34 meals per week
including Gourmet plus keto calorie
smart vegan veggie and 36 plus weekly
add-ons you'll have plenty of nutritious
flavorful options to choose from we all
know the holiday seasons are extremely
busy in fact it's fresh never frozen
meals make it easy to fuel up fast when
I'm on the go and you can save time with
meals delivered ready to heat in just
two minutes Factor has everything I need
for a week of flavorful nutritious eats
in addition to ready meals they have
cold pressed juices smoothie energy
bites extra protein veggie sides and
more to keep me energized during the
Frantic holiday times so head on over to
go.factor75.com
trash60 and use code trash 60 to get 60
off your first boss that's code trash60
at
go.factor75.com trash 60 to get 60 off
your first box do it do it now do it
smash Link in the description back to
the episode I'd like to say the hardest
thing we did was probably the road trip
actually that was like that was hard
that was that was intense just because
our filming schedule was so intense and
our schedule was so intense
um and uh me and Manu shared a room like
a few days uh Emmanuel who is O'Hara who
is uh the person who helped film our
road trip special shout out to horror uh
we should never share a room together
because we have our own personal
schedule when it comes to the morning I
am taking a shower and I'm taking a
shower for as long as I need to take a
shower and he has the same kind of
philosophy as dirty are you huh how
dirty are you sometimes you know
sometimes we're washing away your sins
sometimes sometimes you just need a
certain amount of time just to like wake
like mentally prep for the day what a
bathtub it's called coffee
sit in the bathtub it's like literally
the shower but better but it's I don't I
don't wake up in the bath I fall asleep
in the Box I love starting my morning in
the bath because then I you know you put
it you watch YouTube or something you
just chill getting ready normally
normally bath to me has always been like
if I'm gonna take a bath it's like the
end of the day no no not me as well I
know it's like probably wasteful but I
mean maybe I might even be in the
bathroom in like 10 minutes I guess I
although
yeah although why my head in my equating
time spent in bath equals less waste of
water
it doesn't [ __ ] matter if you think
about it but yeah um I yeah normally
I'll I'll shower I did the Japanese
thing I really like it shower first
remember shower first yeah get all the
the dirtiness off your body whatever and
then go in the bath
you're using water for sure
that is the Japanese that is yeah you
wash off like I'm not I'm not crazy with
it it's like two minutes tops let me
just turn it on get wet and then do all
the Soaps yeah turn it back on rinse I
don't understand it's just for you
Africa
I know it's a waste of water but like
I've never understood people who just go
in the bath I'm like you're just you're
sitting in your own filth
um are you are you I sometimes like
without washing your body off first
Sometimes I will just go in the bath
just for like I just need to like brain
reset and for me I don't know it helps
me relax a lot really I might just jump
at it for 15 minutes I can't relax
knowing the fact that I haven't washed
my body and I'm sitting in water that is
feeling well no if if it's just like
water like I understand for communal
baths because obviously you're like
sharing above so yes you wash off before
if it's just like my own bar yeah it's
just me yeah yeah it's just the water's
like you're not hopefully not that dirty
yeah I'm really muddy yeah yeah I know
that I'm not like I'm not like in a
Rugrats episode
sometimes I just wake up and I'm feeling
extremely lazy to the point where I'm
like I do not want to stand up I want to
sit in this bath and wake up that's what
I'll do like especially if I wasn't like
if I wasn't sweating a lot like a warm
bath right with a hot bath yeah it just
makes me sleepy I'm just not a bath guy
I think [ __ ] love bats man I feel
like it's like a third eye don't like it
you've like reached a new Chalker level
I feel like that's me I feel like that's
me but with showers I can spend like so
much time in the shower but I feel like
it's because I need that like sensation
of like water just hitting my head
talk about being in the shower the whole
time I just I literally just picture you
against the wall like
[Music]
I don't know why
yeah just like just like the movie
protag [ __ ] before you're about to like
I don't know like take over a building
or something I wish I looked I wish I
looked that cool I'm just like not most
of the time I'm just standing in one
place and just like having a [ __ ]
existential crisis or something you know
I'm just like where did
[Laughter]
I think the most Opie [ __ ] in the bath
is a window
say it right now a window window in the
bath is so Opie yeah
outdoors I missed it so much I realized
in the UK we have Windows not bathrooms
and I realized I have to live in Japan
how much I missed that oh you don't know
in the well in my house yeah yeah I do
oh you do but my previous place in most
Japanese houses don't yeah because
they're like it's kind of like its own
room yeah yeah I realized some privacy I
think I think that also might be why I
like this bath so much is that the
window is literally right there the bath
let's get a bunch of sunlight waking up
it's so [ __ ] nice yeah yeah yeah
um unfortunately I'm on the ground
levels uh window doesn't really do it I
already have Windows oh yeah otherwise
my neighbors would see my dick so yeah
that's uh that's for sure yeah yeah no
windows windows in the bathrooms I wish
Japan could have had it more but I get
it because a lot of houses are like like
this close to each other yeah so what
would a window do yeah sure yeah [ __ ] I
love it so much yeah I don't know like I
like I understand why [ __ ] monks need
to meditate under a [ __ ] waterfall
you know there's just some something
calming about the feeling of water just
gushing over your head that just yeah
it's like a little muscle and it's just
like you know I I need a certain amount
of time in the shower every morning just
to be like okay my brain brain wake up
brain you're gonna do this you're gonna
do actually gonna do why if I get out
too early then my brain just it just
feels like my brain hasn't properly
started yet my my favorite [ __ ] thing
is at the hairdressers in Japan after
they like cut your hair or dye your hair
or whatever and then they put you into
that like shower thing yeah back and
then it's like that it's just like that
perfectly pressurized shower that just
concentrates on certain parts
do we all agree that hot tubs admit
yes
yeah okay just making sure I've I've
I've never thought about it but you know
being from like the middle of nowhere in
in the UK you know I always thought hot
tubs were like because you'd see them
all the time on like American stuff hot
tubs hot tubs the coolest [ __ ] and I
always thought it was really [ __ ]
awesome and the first few times I really
think I really liked it but now I kind
of think they're a bit [ __ ] not that
we've had onsen's I'm like how can you
go back to hot tubs are always like and
they never work properly and when they
do the Jets like way too [ __ ]
powerful and you can only felt like
there's always more people it depends
like are you are you just sitting in the
hot tub you have to be drinking right oh
yeah you have to be drinking but like a
lot of the times like either no one
wants to go in the hot tub or way too
many people want to go in the hot tubs
yeah and the water like you know the I
swear to God they're like the most
finicky things to get working
it's it's a really weird thing because
hot tubs have this like really cool
image of being like yeah they do yeah
I'm partying I've got the girls around
me [ __ ] you know look at me got
drinking champagne got some Dom Perignon
you know open that [ __ ] up but then when
you actually have a hot top because I
think it's really telling that in our La
Airbnb where we filmed where we spent
like three weeks in a bunch of episodes
in did so much here we had a hot tub
there I remember going there on the
first day and be like yeah I'm gonna use
this hot tub we never even never use
them never even came close we never took
the covers off it's a mid bath dude
that's like what it is it's like a
mid-back I'm like where's the Onsen yeah
because because the thing the thing is
okay let's say you want to go to like
you're you're at a party right and
there's a hot tub in there
it's such a [ __ ] hassle just to like
change into swimming shorts right yeah
and it's once you and once you get in
the hot tub then there's gonna be a
point where you want to go out and it's
just such a [ __ ] hassle to be in this
hot tub you're at a party and you're
like [ __ ] I'm wet now like I I got to
deal with this [ __ ] you know I just walk
all the way to get a towel yeah dry
myself off and then you have to go
upstairs get changed you smell like pool
water yeah you smell like pool water and
you're like hair's all messy and stuff
now and you're like this is not what I
want to do in like a social situation
you know I'd rather just chill and just
uh talk like any other party yeah but
son is a God too I love saunas so much I
think someone's like the best thing ever
I'm just like I'm indifferent to someone
no yeah I think actually no I hate
someone else but what why I just I'm
just Southeast Asian yeah I just can't I
just can't stand the heat let's just go
outside yeah
yeah yeah yeah
why would you need a sauna saunas are so
good though
so amazing after it it's it's just like
too hot for me same with
is that the whole point of saunas is
that it's really really hot
yeah I know she just like you're just
like it's too hot
I don't like the pool it's everywhere
that's the one I don't like saunas
because
you're trying to move in there you were
in there for like five minutes and then
get out it's just not a pleasant
experience for me I don't know what is
this a weird thing I go in a really
really hot room and I'm like it's really
really hot and I don't feel nice right
now most people I find that don't like
it are the ones who don't want to go in
the cold water
why would you want to oh man it feels
amazing it feels so good when you when
you actually do it it's I genuinely I I
there are a few Sensations on Earth that
make me feel as like satisfied as going
in the sauna going in the [ __ ] ice
ass cold bath they're going back in the
sauna bro people did the [ __ ] ice
bucket challenge because it was a
charity event you know people didn't do
it because it was a pleasant experience
you know no that's that's why people do
when they get off doing like oh this is
all the Europeans are like yes Connor
yes I'm telling you this shit's amazing
also it's very good for you no that's
the thing it's like that's why I'm
indifferent so it's like I don't if I
had the choice to go into it or if I had
didn't have to go into it then I won't
go into it but I know that the health
benefits I'm not convince Chris to do it
I convinced Chris to get in the course
Chris can you believe that in the cold
war in the cold bath I convinced him to
get in it how much did you pay him I
don't I so I mean obviously you guys can
pretty tell that Chris it does if Chris
doesn't want to do something it's very
hard to convince him yeah and and
anything that makes me not comfortable
he won't do I I one time I was like you
should come in the cold there and I went
in and I was like I was like dying I was
like I was like yeah it's on my bed come
in so he put his like foot and he went
and I was like no no if you come on
people you're digging it'll be fine why
don't you get your dick in itself I
think it's the final frontier yeah
because for me like cold baths it's it's
like going from one extreme to the other
yeah that's why it's awesome but like I
I prefer it to be less extreme because
one thing I do like is called Chows cold
Chows is amazing not not in the winter
but if it's like a [ __ ] hot summer's
day this is like every Southeast Asian
right so cold though huh how cold
because colds can be like 30 or cold
could be like 10. oh like I
for me it's like there's a there's a
perfect point for me like even in the
summer in Japan where I'm like okay I
don't want to take a hot shower because
that's yeah I'm so sorry like 20 is like
so it's not like ice cold but it's kind
of like
let's let's let's say you you open the
tap water right and it's just like ten
so yeah about 10. that's that's like
that's to me is like a cold shower right
not ice cold but you know just still
cold it's like un unheated I guess
unheated water but not chilled if that
makes sense lukewarm so what about what
about the cold bath you don't like those
those cold bass are around 10 to 15 as
well normally
um sometimes it's colder depending on
where you are yeah what do you not like
about that but like about the culture
um cold shower I like the fact that
you're not dunking yourself in it it's
kind of like you can you can kind of
like Get acclimated to it a little bit
right that's how you put the pinky and
then the foot and then the leg and then
the pee pee and then the body
yeah because like to me code like a cold
bath is just like too much all at once
right it's it's just not it's just not a
pleasant experience yeah I don't know do
you find it a pleasant experience I like
it a lot now yeah I really like it now
at first it was kind of tough yeah but
now that I love doing it I I [ __ ]
it's the thing I gone for whenever I see
it I think I think the video will be out
by the time this episode's out but I
recently went to go do like the
cryotherapy thing oh yeah you know when
you like put yourself in that like
machine with the liquid nitrogen they
blast you with the liquidation oh yeah
three minutes yeah it was horrible but
it was like but it was like a reverse
sauna if you think about it it's like
instead of you're getting blessed by
like you know 80 90 degrees it's like
100 and 10 130 and it's like I I felt it
was [ __ ] while you were in it but the
moment you walk out and you're like you
sit in front of what they call a red
light it's not it's not a heater it's
just you trick the brain into looking at
a red light and thinking that it's warm
but there's no heat right your body's
gonna heat up naturally yeah and like
that natural progression of like heating
myself up again I was like okay now I
can see why this feels good would I do
it again no I'll tell you what the
perfect balance was for me in terms of
like the nice feeling going from hot to
cold remember that ski resort we went to
earlier this year and it was like deep
in Winter we went to the outside Onsen
[ __ ] freezing outside it was really
windy so what you do is you dunk your
body into the Onsen get a bit toasty and
then you just stand up and you just I've
never fell off four or three in my life
you're standing [ __ ] naked with the
[ __ ] ice cold wind blowing on myself
so to explain how cool it was if you
were sitting in there and you didn't
like wet your hair constantly it would
freeze like your hair would actually
turn solid it was averaging about minus
ten cells yeah so so we were so we were
in the
even though we were sitting in this
Onsen which was you know bath
temperature our hair would be frozen you
know our hair would be clearly my
favorite thing about it which is kind of
weird is like you know how you said you
felt like powerful like standing on yeah
I felt more powerful because like you
stand upright and and your body is just
like it the the hot air is just turning
into like Vapor yeah as well so it's
like oh it's like gear too yeah
it was like is this how loot you feel
it's like get a second bro I don't know
what that is
happening I love it but now I'm cold
holy [ __ ] that body is upset
I think having a cold shower or a cold
bath is very good for blood pressure I
think correct I believe so yeah um a lot
of people in like uh Nordic countries or
like uh Iceland they because they tend
to have cold showers or do the cold uh
don't run in the river or some [ __ ] the
dunk run foreign
[Music]
it's interesting I don't know I
definitely feel so much more relaxed and
like I don't know the next day I feel
amazing after I do it every time during
the cycling thing that I did with Chris
I was like one or two of the days there
was a sauna and it was like it was like
a relief it was like God tier I felt so
ready the next day no I totally get it
like and and I know that like you know
again there is like you know properly
scientifically backed you know health
benefits to doing sortas and Ice baths
and stuff like that yeah but like I know
that but it's like I still don't really
want to do it I I understand
I don't care about the health benefits
this is like this is like me eating
salad because I think it tastes good and
then I'm like oh actually it is really
good for you it's like okay I understand
I know that I just I'm just saying I
just don't find it a pleasant experience
so I don't I don't normally want to do
it I'm driving you next time I would do
it I'll do it I would do it I'd be more
inclined to do it if there were other
people yeah because I've been in store
I've been in stores it's very fun with
your friends yeah
experience like I've ever had right sure
which is a bunch of Mace convinced me to
go to the sauna because like yeah we're
gonna chill in there hang out and I'm
like oh [ __ ] here we go again here we go
here we go again okay I throwing me
dragon into this thing and so you know
you go you go in the sauna I sit down
instantly my ass is way too [ __ ] hot
it feels like it's [ __ ] searing and
everyone's having a nice conversation
and I'm like fighting for my life right
now I'm like everyone's like yeah this
feels so good right now
like reacts first for me because like
for me it's like my lungs feel like
they're on fire oh my lungs as well yeah
so you breathe through your uh mouth
your mouth yeah but it's still you
breathe through your mouth and you're
just slow coming into you like every
breath of mine hurts you sit down with
your ass is searing and it's just like
you know what it is I don't even think
it's the heat that I don't like about
saunas I just don't like sweating no
that's that's right no that's the good
part about it though yeah I know I know
that's the good part but I I feel gross
when I sweat yeah so I think I that's
the part I don't like about saunas is
that it's not even the heat that's the
issue you're about to go back in like a
bath or something right yeah but like
just sitting there just like [ __ ]
drenched in sweat I'm just like I don't
like this feeling okay you really like
saunas how do you feel about steam rooms
uh they're okay okay I feel like steam
rooms are like beta saunas in my mind
because I'm realizing Maybe is because
I'm from Southeast Asia because I think
steam rooms feel nice so
I I like the like in my head they're
just inferious I like the heavy air in
the steam rooms you know it feels it
feels like yeah maybe maybe I just like
the heavier the humidity but I would
always prefer sauno because the sauna I
really hate like I hate like all of the
theater I hate like the feeling of like
sweating and it's like I don't know my
my skin feels really itchy I don't have
that in Steam rooms I still like the
Heats still a bit too hot but I would
pick a steam room over a sauna any day
of the week nah just just put me in a
nonsense bro I love the you know there's
nothing more fun than being able to chat
in a sauna and you just feel so powerful
you feel like you're like you could do
anything and you're discussing anything
in the sauna for me I'm just thinking
when when is it like a socially
acceptable time to leave like whatever
you want to because I'm always that guy
who's just like I don't want to be the
[ __ ]
I've been there for like 10 seconds
you're like you can leave any time and
I'm like a second your body you're still
figuring out what the [ __ ] is going on
like you're not even heating up at that
point you're just you've still got your
old body like temperature
at least two minutes you're not you yet
if you go out at two minutes I'd be like
that's fine just not used to it like
five minutes is typical five five
minutes is when you normally that's like
a normal set yeah then you can go out
okay so okay so do you do you handle
being too hot or being too cold better
too cold too cold right because I like
same for me I handled too cold better
than being too hot which is why in
onsense I'm always the first one to
[ __ ] leave the bath I'm never going
in the sauna and stuff like that because
when I when it feels like my body's
cooking that's when I don't know I just
that's a much less pleasant experience
for me than being a bit too chilly or
something yeah it's weird though it's
obviously like being in like a let's say
you're stuck in a jungle it's like way
less dangerous than being stuck in like
an actual cold exactly
I think I get that uh thing because it's
like I think subconsciously in my head
I'm like it's worse being hot because
there's literally nothing I can do after
being naked yeah you know it's like it's
like I'm butt naked and I'm still hot or
that's bad but like if I'm cold I'll
just be like oh just put another layer
on yeah it's like an easy fix but
there's no easy fix when you're butt
naked and hot at the same time you know
it's like what the [ __ ] do I do let me
just remove my skin you can't do that
it's like what am I doing okay now I'm
in danger yeah yeah
I think subconsciously I have that but
yeah again I just don't like sweating
yeah I mean no one likes non-likes I
actually I kind of like sweating yeah
right I like sweating when it's
controlled when I'm sure yeah like if
I'm at the gym I love sweating at the
gym like when I've got a good sweat
going man okay sweating at the gym I'm
okay with that as well because I'm doing
that to myself you know and that and
that is like a sign of like oh what I am
currently doing and spending time with
is working right but the sauna I'm not
doing anything I'm just sitting there
sweating
yeah I'm like there's no there's no
difference in going outside in Japan
there's no difference in going outside
in Japan during the summer
turn off the sauna
the sauna is always
on we installed an AC in our sauna just
in here yeah our Southeast Asians we
look at like you like Europeans like you
actually you you pay to go in a sauna
you paid a sweat yeah yeah we just do
that naturally man what are you talking
about I think there's something like
Angela Merkel always starts her day off
in a sauna or something or something
like that it just sounds I know every
day sounds excessive yeah I know it's
like a stigma but it just sounds
incredibly pretentious I I guess because
like sauna's uh outside of um certain
European countries they are a luxury yes
in certain European countries that
pretty much everywhere but but
everywhere else it's kind of like you
have to be a rich [ __ ] to have a
sauna yeah
sure well do you know anyone with that
has a sauna in their house I should go
away from the UK yeah yeah like in the
UK it's a luxury thing yeah yeah exactly
you know if you went to some European
countries it's way more common really
cool what's like having a pool in the UK
right a pool is like the biggest
indicator that you are way too much
exactly there's no there's no [ __ ]
neat reason for porn like three days a
year yeah you have five days tops so you
can use that [ __ ] yeah and then you've
got a pace you want to keep cleaning it
no yeah
do you think uh in the UK do you think
more houses in the UK should have like
AC yeah of course I every every shocks
me that you guys don't have AC yeah
every every house on earth should have
one of those heat pumps
um which is like the common uh those ACS
the ones that can cold and oh they're
way more effective than those giant like
um AC block things you see in America
yeah
um yeah I think every everywhere she had
them I mean I I think it makes way more
sense than having these because in the
UK we have these giant radiators
attached to like every room and these
these just giant metallic things that
just like heat throughout the room and
it's so inefficient and it's like can I
just have like one radiator like one
nice efficient thing that blows hot air
and then takes it out but obviously all
the houses in the UK were made before
um yeah because I was saying I was
thinking like now living in Japan with a
unit that can do both AC and heating I'm
just like white and dry and dry as well
I'm just like why is why is it so far
hard to find an AC unit in the UK
because well you know even if you'll use
it like one two weeks in a year when we
get that [ __ ] Heat Wave this like the
heat wave just seems to be getting more
and more and more extreme every [ __ ]
year and every year that goes by I'm
like yo people will need to like the UK
needs to start having at least some kind
of cooling unit because everyone's gonna
[ __ ] die like two weeks you should
fix a lot of things on a lot of things
everything everything actually now I
think about it just pretty much
everything yeah because I think modern
houses have it though like newer houses
yeah newer houses I'm sure have it but I
was I was shocked because I remember the
first time I went to the UK and I was a
[ __ ] place and that was during that
heat wave yeah right and it was like it
was night time and it was like what 30
degrees still and I'm like oh [ __ ] this
is like a Japanese summer night I'm like
oh all right I better turn the AC on and
I'm looking around for the remote in
God's room I'm like
where is it I think God's mom comes in
with the [ __ ] like old school like
fans here you go
that [ __ ] does nothing that [ __ ] that
just moves hot air around that does not
cool me down at all yeah that that is
the Southeast Asian experience yeah it's
we we just back at my grandma's house we
have fans which is like
even during the heat wave at least we
had fans because I know a lot of my
mates in the UK they didn't even have
fans I don't know how they [ __ ]
survived honestly I didn't have fans I
remember I was just suffering I remember
it's just awful but also isn't it is it
South Korea where leaving a fan on while
sleeping is like you'll die really it's
like a Superstition is that crazy and I
swear on South Korea I think if you
leave the fan on while you're sleeping
you'll die
you just [ __ ] die oh I'm [ __ ] dead
then because yeah right since Sydney
needs a fan on at all times when she's
sleeping wait even when it's cold yeah
even when it's cold because it's because
of the noise it's it's like it's like
the
it's like comforting to her I guess I
don't like that like the the what is it
called the not white White Noise White
Noise background background I was gonna
say background radiation that's not what
I'm saying radiation did you find
anything I just put a tub of uranium in
my room yeah if you run the fan with no
open Windows
well yeah I don't know why are you in
hell guys I feel like I had this
conversation with Emily and Emily said
that to me yeah normally said it to me
or something in Japan I think it's like
if you sleep with the fan on or the AC
on yeah and you don't have like anything
to cover up your stomach then it's like
you know then my grandma's like oh you
got your call the AC demon will kill you
central air will come down and kill you
for me I don't know if this was a
Superstition but for me if you go to bed
with your if you go to sleep when your
hair's still wet then you'll just wake
up with a cold oh dude everyone in Japan
says this yeah yeah
and I'm like bet I'm doing that just to
spite you and I because I I it's it's
like internal lies into me because I
remember I I was like my mom would
always sell this to me right if you go
to if you're too bad with your hair wet
you're gonna get a cold I'm like Batman
I did it once I got a cold so I was like
[ __ ] mom was right she knows huh is
there any scientific proof behind this I
don't know if there's any scientific
proofs maybe it's just like yeah if you
had really long hair I could be like oh
well yeah because it's not going to dry
but if you have like our hair yeah that
[ __ ] will dry in like 40 minutes dude
I'm I think it might just be like you
know the hair your hair gets cold when
it's wet and then that coldness just
like gets to your head yeah
I also had an urban myth here that some
people were telling me like some
Japanese people they were like if you go
outside with wet hair you're more likely
to get like sick or get germs or some
[ __ ] because apparently it somehow keeps
germs or something I was like it's like
what the [ __ ] you talking about bro I'm
using the natural AC to dry my hair
also germs aren't that smart to be like
yo how moisture yeah I don't know any
any evidence behind this no they said
that it's not possible it's not possible
yeah you get a cold yeah okay well it's
like the urban myth where it's like if
you go out in the rain for too long then
you're gonna get a cold as well and I'm
like what where did these Urban myths
come from I guess well I think I think
actually if you are if your body's
actually colder you have way more chance
of getting sick yeah but then there are
some especially Japanese ones that just
don't make any sense like oh if you open
on an umbrella indoors then you're gonna
get struck by lightning oh and it's like
it's just bad luck if you do it yeah we
just have bad luck yeah it's just
unspecified bad luck in the in the west
skilled skill issue clearly I'm like no
God will strike you down if you leave
the umbrella
you will be smighted every time I go
into an umbrella store I'm sweating I'm
like I want to see what this umbrella
looks like but I will be smited I see
that all the time leaving The Umbrellas
again it's just like an urban you know
legend or you know myth or whatever it
is yeah urban urban legend people yeah
the real doll where you put it down
ah sorry yeah yeah yeah so you know like
in Japan there's the territory yeah
where you can you can stop the rain so
in Japan like as a kid uh you would do
this thing where you'd build it it
usually just be like out of tissues or
something but it'd just be like a little
snowman looking thing and if it's it's
raining and you put it up on your
windowsill then the thing is that like
the the next day it'll be sunny you know
just kind of like a little thing that
kids are taught yeah there's an urban
legend that if you do that but if you
hang it up upside down then it's going
to be raining the next day and I'm like
oh yeah I'm sure I'm sure whether you
know the weather is just looking at
being like all right how many of them
are [ __ ] time around people just want
to make their life more interesting and
that's that's how it is this is just
astrology with extra steps I sort of
swear to God like yo yo what direction
you're too
oh you're probably a Libra
[Laughter]
oh my God it's true it's it's like it's
like you know you know the [ __ ] nem
test but like they test like your
[ __ ] which which like specifications
like your nanis it's just it's just that
basically right except it's just
complete [ __ ] [ __ ] man if only if
only we had real men right yeah Omega
lives so much easier
yeah exactly exactly yeah where you're
facing north do you believe in that feng
shui [ __ ] no
and all that [ __ ] too and like
all anything it's like it's I'll be
honest I just don't believe in anything
straight up it's just nothing
I just don't believe I don't believe I'm
just here to have fun clearly I hear
Don't Stop Believing I'm like bet
not you journey
is it is sometimes my life not that fun
yeah but like I you know it's just what
I chose to live my life so do you do I
get it like because like do you do you
do you identify as a realist
or an atheist lots of realist I've never
heard of what is a realist like as the
name suggests it's just like you only
believe in things that are like
factually true true like scientifically
backed and just like things that are you
know I mean science grounded in reality
you know science science [ __ ] up a lot
um
a [ __ ]
they are they are step on a crack break
your mum's better who the [ __ ] made that
up that's [ __ ] quite frankly because
you're not coming with any other I
remember when I was eight and my friend
said that to me I was just like crack
um you know I just think that for me it
seems like a lot of people who enjoy
that kind of stuff or like like talking
about it like um like the whole uh
what's the [ __ ] star sign [ __ ]
astrology yeah like that's just like
something fun for people to kind of feel
like they they kind of know people or
categorize people in a more of a
comforting way because the world is
scary if you think that everyone is just
like operating on their own and has no
kind of purpose yeah they are like I I
think that like dude I mean there's a
lot of stuff I don't understand and I
don't think it's because they're a
[ __ ] Libra
[Music]
I don't subscribe to that notion of like
hey if I don't believe in this thing
neither should you I'm like hey if you
if you want to believe that because gone
is what are you a cancer I'm a Gemini
actually what are you trying to say
you know do you think he gives off
cancer energy he kind of did yeah every
attention player no I am not a cancer
but if it's fun if it's fun for you to
hear like the answer Gemini and then
kind of be like oh yeah you can have it
you know then fine yeah whatever like
that's I don't give a [ __ ] no no I'm
totally the same it's like if you want
to believe in it you can believe in it
but just don't shove that [ __ ] down my
throat yeah don't don't like make me
feel don't demonize me phenomenally
weird for not believing yeah and because
you know you flipped a penny four times
that the the Zeus is going to come down
and jack you off like I just I don't I'm
not
I feel stuff like that they told me to
do that on the Cosmopolitan magazine so
uh I have to believe it I just think
people are bored and that's how they
keep themself busy yeah people people
everyone's just distracting themselves
in one way or another people be dumb I
know I don't I don't think I'm smarter
than anyone else I just think and I
think a lot of people who know who are
like who like to talk about like say
star signs it's like they don't actually
like genuinely heart like deep down
believe in that [ __ ] A lot of people do
you'd be surprised there are some people
right I'm not saying that I'm smarter
than them because I don't it's like
there's some people who but I am saying
I am smarter though
whatever it's what you do like I I was
[ __ ] with a lot of things that's just
one thing that I don't believe in and I
don't think that makes me better than
you that's why but that's why I think
just like it doesn't matter what you
believe in everyone thinks everyone is
dumber than everyone else right so
everyone thinks they're smarter than
they are as well there's been like a
bunch of studies where if you ask people
are you average above average or
whatever people normally say like
they're like above average yeah which
obviously doesn't make sense well
if everyone is special no one is special
I believe Walt Disney said that I don't
know if that's true actually
I'm just I'm just quiet it was it was
Sun Tzu in the heart of the Art of War I
think who said that Vladimir
[Music]
he said all the things this episode is
sponsored by zenmarket guys look at all
this cool stuff look at all with this
cool stuff that we got in Japan when you
want some of that as well I do I bet you
do well why not use zenmarket it's a
proxy shipping service that will ship
you any of the items that you can only
get in Japan right to your door
zenmarket has a flat rate service of 300
Yen around two dollars U.S no matter how
expensive an item is the service fee
will stay the same no matter what and
send Market accepts multiple payment
methods including PayPal wise and Bank
transfers and if you purchase items on
rack 10 on Wednesday and Thursday you
can get five percent cash back don't
forget that zenmarket added rakoma
rockton's online flea market recently
check out the rakoma banner on our page
and you will be able to find anime
figures and goods for a steal so get
yourself some cool merch you can only
get from Japan today so smash that link
in the description down below to go to
Zen market today back to the episode
best meme of 2022. why are you asking
because I was like trying to I was
trying to ask ask the meme man yeah yeah
can you remember like what memes were
big this year because I'm trying to
think okay what's what's like some big
events that happened this year I don't
know why like the I don't know it's it's
it feels sad to me like it feels
genuinely sad that I remembered the Will
Smith's the Will Smith slap before some
of the more political things that
happened this year like yeah yeah uh
yeah [ __ ] oh that was this year wasn't
it [ __ ]
[Music]
this has just been like a mess of a
[ __ ] yeah do you reflect a lot in the
year normally or are you more of uh
let's get on the next year ah yeah I I
normally reflect on like at the end of
every year normally on like in in that
period in December where you're just
like oh what did I do this year oh that
was really really cool now how do I
one-up it next year and you're like [ __ ]
I did a lot this year how do I what up
it next year are you are you the kind of
person to set yourself like New Year's
resolutions or are you just kind of like
uh no whatever happens I think I think
we talked about this last year we did I
can't remember what our last Year's
resolutions were uh sorry for the battle
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna hope that
we uh we we did it I hope so yeah do you
have any resolutions this year let's
let's not call it resolutions do you
have any goals for next year goals yeah
that's hard enough right
[Music]
you're going more saunas Yeah the more
money more more saunas yes more ski
trips I want to be more active next year
I think like physically you said this
long I remember yeah saying this last
year I think I think I was I think this
year if there was a resolution I said
that I actually fulfilled this year
compared to last year is that I have
definitely become more physically active
this year yeah but I feel like we can go
further Beyond you know like I feel like
what do you mean like how what was the
difference between like last year and
this year then okay well last year I
wouldn't get up off my ass at all like
zero percent uh active I didn't I wasn't
at the going to the gym which I am now
yeah uh you know I wasn't doing any like
physical like sport I wasn't going out
and like just [ __ ] touching grass and
doing [ __ ] yeah this year you know I
like at least like once or twice a month
I've like gone out to do some kind of
physical activity with some friends or
whatever or you know like just go on
more walks and you know obviously go
back to the gym and [ __ ] but like I feel
like I don't know I I definitely can
just get more [ __ ] done if I just find
myself in a routine every week
regardless of what the schedule might be
so I just want to like find that one
thing other than the gym where I can
just kind of do something physical for
fun you know where I can like keep
myself healthy and like do some fun
because like you know when I was growing
up I did like a lot of like tennis and
like cricket and footy and stuff like
that so it's like I kind of want to like
go back to that Rhythm because you know
I did tennis for like [ __ ] 10 years
or something and that [ __ ] was so fun
and Incredibly healthy yeah but the
problem is a I don't know uh anyone who
plays tennis and B renting out tennis
courts are [ __ ] pain in the ass in
Tokyo so yeah yeah anything that is
tough like you know it's so easy yeah to
get any of that stuff yeah same in
Australia you just [ __ ] rock up and
be like oh okay here's somebody give me
the court yeah that's literally is it
not that way in Japan no
because of course Japan has to make
everything so [ __ ] too fast it's
because we are in like the like one of
the most dense populated metropolitan
areas in the world right so having a
tennis court is just finding finding a
tennis court is a struggle so they have
them it's just it's for like it's like
the elite like if you if you you want to
have a good tennis court that is
available to you often and you don't
have to book far ahead you need to be in
like some kind of Club yeah and then and
they're not cheap in Tokyo they're
expensive like if you want to do a sport
in Tokyo you need to know you want to do
the sport it is an absolute luxury and
it's expensive and if you don't have
anyone to deal with then it just becomes
like tedious so touching grass here is a
luxury oh yeah oh yeah it is we're in
[ __ ] Concrete Jungle of Asia dude
like it's [ __ ] it's impossible it's for
anything like that but uh yeah so I kind
of want to like I'm just throwing away
tennis being like all right that's not
it I need to find something else to do
so I thought about like rock climbing
and [ __ ] because that might that's
actually easier yeah yeah yeah there's
um there's a few really good ones um I
know there's a really big change in
Japan called pump and they have a ton of
locations all around they've won this
really cool it's in akihabra it's like I
went to that one the one where you can
go to the roof and Overlook Akihabara
while you're climbing yeah yeah that one
was sick it's really good workout as
well for your arms yeah [ __ ] absolutely
yeah your upper body just gets [ __ ]
yeah dude man I that's that's the one
thing about if you don't go to the like
if you don't work out regular enough and
you're kind of doing it like on and off
it's like you constantly just lose that
progress you made so every single time
you go back to the gym and like do legs
or do arms pain I did like three days
ago and it's the first time I've done
legs in like two months and I just
couldn't walk for like two days like an
idiot when I go to the toilet and it's
like great
just want to link to the toilet okay
it's just like oh my God he's already
shooting himself I know one of those
exercises how to keep up with every time
you try to reset it beat your ass yeah
yeah do you have any uh goals yeah I
have I have a few goals uh I want to
touch more grass and also less grass at
the same time
explain yourself
explain myself okay so I I do want to go
on like more small trips and stuff like
that uh but I've kind of set myself a
goal to like go and go in like one more
small trips and just not make content
out of it I guess because I realized
this year I did a [ __ ] ton this year I
did so much [ __ ] traveling this year
compared to basically like the rest of
my life but a lot of that was like films
a lot of that was like content yeah and
I had this I had this realization uh
when I was uh on my stag do and uh we
were doing uh we were doing surfing and
it was just like I just I just realized
oh my God this is just like such a
pleasant experience to just do this new
activity and not feel like oh I need to
be entertaining I need to be
entertaining or oh I'm learning when I'm
gonna be competing against the boys in
about two hours you know
it was it was it was such a weird mental
thing where I'm just like wait I can
just enjoy yeah enjoy the activities
this is why weekend trips at op just get
away for like a day or two yeah yeah so
good you don't feel stressed you're like
I'm not putting off work it's like two
days yeah sure yeah that's a luxury yeah
so yeah I want to go on I want to go on
more like small trips
um and just not have a pressure to
like film it make content around it just
looks so weird if you're like a normal
person listening what do you mean
YouTube you have to stop yourself from
filming everything what the [ __ ] yeah
well it's it's kind of like it's it's
it's weird right because we've talked
about our Hobbies becoming our jobs and
how that changes your approach to things
right so before you know we had this
like you know anime was my hobby and
then it became my job and then I needed
to change how I approached anime as a
medium because it was my job but also I
still enjoyed it you know and now since
starting trash days now since filming so
much of my life has essentially become
part of my job even like the smallest
things I've needed to like change my
mentality around right because you know
doing all this cool things traveling
around Japan
um you know going to the you know seeing
all these cool places it's great I know
but it's it's still an amazing
experience that I can talk about and
stuff like that but it's not the same as
going there on holiday you know it's
it's not because you're still
technically working there
um and it's it's nice to be able to hit
both you know both boxes to be like I
travel to a cool place and also I was
able to make money out of it as well so
it wasn't uh you know it wasn't a
complete write-off in terms of my time
but I I you know I feel like it's to me
I've kind of realized traveling around
and stuff like that traveling for work
traveling for trash taste is very very
different from traveling for holiday as
well so basically I want to take more
holidays
how we arrange it so I think all the
trash day shoots we've been we're we're
pretty intense like we yeah we schedule
things very tight and we don't really
leave much room to enjoy the trips but
like whenever I travel with Chris Chris
is very adamant that he wants to do like
we wake up at 11 and we stop filming at
four and then he's like and we have a
day off and it's like all right okay wow
all right that's a lot more manageable a
lot more fun yeah yeah but also I get
really agitated something I want to buy
wasting so much time
maybe that's the point Conor maybe
that's the point you know yeah he's not
wasting time he's
I second the whole like you know wanting
to travel more and [ __ ] yeah because um
I have this app on my phone called Bean
like b-e-e-n yeah it's basically just
like uh I think Google Maps has it as
well but it's basically like an app
where you can track like you know which
parts of the world you've been to and
like stuff like that and I looked and I
was looking at it just you know randomly
a few nights ago and I was like oh man
it says I've I've visited six percent of
the world
right and I'm like [ __ ] that could be
higher like I I want I like I want
there's I realize looking at the map and
like where it's like white it out there
is gamified he's traveling now I'm just
like no I just realized I'm like I
thought in my head I visited a lot of
the world and then you know I have you
know on the grander scale of things but
it's like people developed worlds yeah
yes of course but like there's also so
many parts of the wall but I still
haven't been to that I want to go to
yeah and it's like and again it's like
that it's that mental fight of like the
YouTuber brain kicks in where I go okay
should I go and film it yeah or should I
go just to enjoy it and experience it
yeah the real question is do I want to
deduct this on my taxes or do I not want
them to do this see that is awesome
that's not my YouTuber that's just like
I'm like how can I save money how can I
everything is a tax writer
and [ __ ] the government over yeah quite
frankly if I can do both then hey I'll
take that [ __ ] you know know but it's
like yeah that's that's another thing
it's like I kind of want to just like go
and explore more of the world while I
still can yeah because you know God
forbid something might happen you know
in our careers or in our lives or in our
health where you won't be able to do
that [ __ ] anymore so it's like why not
take that opportunity I've always been
at the mentality of like if the
opportunity comes up just [ __ ] take
it because you never know you never know
that might never come again right so
it's like just just take it while you
can even if it sucks at the time it'll
be something cool that you'll remember
and think fondly of and you know
utilizing the next opportunity so that's
something I want to do with like travel
uh for next year and it's like I have
like a short list of countries I've
always wanted to go to where I'm like I
think next year might be the year where
I start ticking those off yeah it's like
why not yeah I mean luckily I I went to
Australia for the first time this year
that was a lot a lot of fun I definitely
want to go back to Australia yeah I mean
possibly New Zealand as well yes I don't
exist huh doesn't exist it's just it
doesn't exist it's just an island on
Australia
and I also don't want to travel the
world at the same time kind of lazy
yeah don't play TFT
because that's the thing I said I want
to touch more grass and I also I want to
touch less grass as well a part of me
part of me feels like I
where I'm at right now in like and I
suppose with like career and all that
stuff even if I travel to these places I
don't think I would fully appreciate it
yeah I think I would want to wait until
I've actually just slowed down a little
bit Yeah and then I won't then I'll be
able to enjoy it and be more excited
about it I think if I went now and
traveled to all these places it'd be
like when I did it when I was like 15.
like I because my my dad lived in uh
lived in a different country uh while
working in a different country so we
we're always traveling Europe a lot and
I [ __ ] thought Europe sucks yeah
because I was like 12 and I just want to
play a game boy and now I'm like [ __ ]
man I I should have I should have found
26 and want to play TFT and then people
ask me they're like they're like oh
where have you been in Europe might have
been here here here here like like most
of the European countries I've been to
except for like the Eastern ones and I
was like oh
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] remember anything
about Malta I don't [ __ ] remember
anything like what if I I just remember
it was like everyone drank a lot well
did you go but that's just because you
went as a kid right yeah yeah but I was
like I was like 15 16 and I could have
done I could have definitely could have
remembered stuff yeah yeah I was like I
don't know like I've been in a ton of
countries as well when I was a kid which
I want to go back to to re-appreciate it
because I don't either don't remember it
fondly or you know you going to you
going somewhere as a kid versus you
going there as an adult like if you
realize adult it's completely because
the biggest difference is you know what
you want to do on like when you go
somewhere I don't want to eat yeah I
want to try the Local Foods I want to
just explore the local areas and just
find like some cool hidden gems because
I remember why I hated traveling as a
kid is because we'd always travel with
family or something and you couldn't
choose and you can choose what you want
to do so everyone would like there would
always be that one person in the group
that just wanted to go to like see like
the biggest monuments or like the big
biggest tourist things to go to and I'm
like I find it's boring as [ __ ] like I
do not like this therefore I do not like
travel so I am just going to understand
going to notch touch grass and then I
realize now that I've done more
traveling it's just like oh if you
actually do [ __ ] that you want to do
instead of just doing going by someone
else's schedule as you can see it's
actually [ __ ] enjoyable yeah you know
I'm also dude I'm guilty of this I don't
know if you guys do this either I'm a
hotel Fiend I stay at my hotel a lot
like when I travel if I'm I'm chilling
I'll stay in the hotel till like 2 p.m
I'll be like I noticed that during the
tour yeah like I'm just I just like to
chill out chill in the room for a bit
because I'm like on my head I'm like I'm
on vacation yeah I'll sleep as long as I
want I want to take my sweet ass time
getting ready yeah I want to nap a ton I
nap so [ __ ] much when I'm on vacation
no because I'm like 2 p.m time for one
hour nap yeah for 20 minutes because I'm
when I'm traveling I'm not the kind of
traveler who tries to fill up their oh
[ __ ] schedule as much as possible you
know I like if if I just find one cool
place in the new area I'm going to even
if it's just even if it's just like one
little area that's enough of me you know
I don't need to see like the entirety of
it just just because I'm a whole I'm on
holiday yeah right my schedule's packed
enough as it is off from my job I just
want to go buy my own schedule see I'm
I'm the complete opposite yeah I've
noticed like when I'm going somewhere
especially if it's somewhere I've never
been to I'm like I don't know when I'm
going to be here next so I want to see
as much of it as I can while I'm here
yeah so I'm like never in my hotel
funnily enough I was like the the only
time I've been like that is when we were
touring America right because right
because I remember like almost every
city I was like trying to do something
or meet someone who are new there and I
I just got to see like quite a lot of
America but I feel like it was weird for
me because that was that wasn't a
holiday for me that was like work so I
was like I'm going to take advantage of
this because I'm traveling America and
it's I'm on a work schedule anyway so I
ain't got time to relax but if I'm
actually going on a holiday holiday
I want to do nothing basically oh yeah I
want to do nothing yeah
I get that man I I really want to go
back to Europe now and just like go
around eat all the good food yeah yeah
you guys had a super good and you never
realized well no because I also like I
remember we traveled a lot because
um my parents
um
you know they wouldn't really buy us
like any like material things it was
always like we'll go on experience yeah
we'll go on vacation instead and as a
kid I was like I'd rather have an Xbox
but
um yeah I never got the Xbox
but I remember that when we did travel
Europe because my mum we would do it on
like because we would normally go
camping rice we would drive there yeah
camps it was like it was all done on
like a really big budget so we'd never
buy food it was always like you would
buy the market cap ingredients and cook
and I'm like [ __ ] man wish I'd tried
some of the yeah but I wouldn't have
appreciated it as well knowing me yeah I
always just ordered pizza anyway
whenever I went anywhere
across Europe every single single time
we ever went to a restaurant Which rare
I'd be like pizza
it's fair enough you know what you like
and uh because you're like when you're
like 15 you're like damn they're they're
two Foods pizza
that's it at least
okay okay sorry that's why people sorry
otherwise people will be like no we
don't we don't claim him no they're not
okay come get your hands I also want to
touch less grass as well how sure want
to play more video games I [ __ ] yeah man
I do but I don't at the same time yeah I
do but I don't at the same time I'm like
I can I can do that in my retirements
yes sometimes I play games and I think
man was it worth it
was it worth losing a day like I I like
even if it's a game you're enjoying
right
um some side effect really depends like
Elton ring I never felt that like the
[ __ ] was so God tier that I felt like I
had to that's what you get for being a
[ __ ] TFT player man oh yeah Tiffany
if I spent a day playing League or TFT
or OverWatch something like that uh I I
do regret it oh yes that's why I stopped
playing competitive games because it
always feels like it's so easy to get
addicted and into the garage yeah but I
I always felt like after I finished
playing it I'd wasted a day especially
if you're on the ranked table and you
lose yeah you're like okay I made
negative progress today and I didn't do
anything I just got annoyed but that's
why it's great like in places like I
really enjoy like like as you well know
um portable gaming I don't particularly
prefer it but I do like the fact that I
don't feel bad if I would put my laptop
and play a game of TFT at the airport
yeah I I I'm like I don't feel guilty
about that I'm killing time and I'm I'm
enjoying it yeah yeah yeah which is why
I like seem like you'd like a lot I
[ __ ] love my steam deck start the
trail series now that's good that's my
New Year's resolution
play more games bro just like life away
I'm like if you know what if you don't
if you don't know what that is good good
don't find out oh yeah we talked about
it we talked about in a previous episode
and I followed through I'm 15 hours into
uh the first Trails game
I bought the game and but I haven't
started yet I'm scared bro I think I've
only had like in the past like two weeks
since we spoke about it I've had like
two hours three tops yeah it's it's I
would never have started playing it if I
didn't have my steam deck so I didn't
realize this but when we're on tour like
um in America you could just buy a steam
deck where and now in Japan
just now but we've been on a waiting
list for like months and months and
months here in Japan uh so I bought one
to Sydney's house and I had a steam deck
and I didn't know what to play but like
now I've just been you know just it's
just been my activity to do before I go
to bed it's just perfect perfect little
jrpg play go to bed and just you know uh
yeah I really wanted to get it and I was
on the waiting list yeah he did like 10
bucks to go on the waiting list in Japan
yeah and I've got the email like two
days ago three days ago that was like
hey you can you can now get it if you
want right and I saw the prices like
it's a grand and I was like
damn it's a grand for the the good model
oh it's a gaming PC it's a portable game
yeah I just kind of was like I actually
don't think I'm gonna use it like and as
much as like because I yeah I I really
wanted it just because I'm like I'm a
huge Tech guy I [ __ ] love my tech I
love getting Tech yeah and I wanted to
get it just because I really admired the
product and I thought what it did was
amazing yeah but I did I just sat there
I was like I actually just don't like
realistically am I gonna use it can't
play TFT not going to use it yeah I
can't I like it should like it doesn't
work on it right so I don't know that
was that was the straw that broke the
camera
I sat down and I thought yeah genuinely
like watch Steam games do I actually
play yeah yeah and I realized I was like
no I literally don't play Steam games
that's why that's why I didn't even get
onto the waiting list because I'm like I
don't play I play steam as it is yeah it
looked cool I just thought it'd be fun
because like you you say like do do you
feel like you wasted a day playing video
games and like you know playing playing
the games I am now finishing God of War
you know playing the trail series now I
don't feel like I wasted a day actually
because that's games you like actually
like you know are invested in one yeah
I'm going to remember my experience I'm
not gonna forget my experience with god
of war and stuff like that that's
something that's going to stick with me
and that's why I like story driven games
right that's because it's it's something
that I'm going to remember the
experience playing this game I don't
feel like I wasted a day by making
progress in this game because I do feel
like I am making progress in this game
you know so it's just like yeah I'm
going to remember my time with it so no
I don't feel like I'm going to waste it
makes sense yeah I kind of have that
same feeling with like when I like read
a book or something right where it's
like you know some people be like oh am
I wasting a day reading a book yeah I
was like well not really because you
know at the end of the day like a story
driven game you are remembering a story
and that story anything that makes you
happy is not positive or negative way is
going to have an impact on you right
yeah what you can choose to use you can
choose not to use yeah but like with
like a competitor game for instance it's
like I'm not as invested in it because
at the end of the day the only thing I'm
going to remember is was I pissed off at
the end of the day yeah did I make
progress no well
after our Guilty Gear stream I was like
[ __ ] I really want to play more guilty
here
I was just like I really really do but I
I just like the thing that's stopped me
it's just I just I just don't gel with
competitive games right because I get to
this point where I really like I really
like learning competitive games but when
I get past that point and I feel like
you're just grinding the ladder you've
learned the mechanics
um I just that's when I start feeling
like I've wasted time on this game you
know well I think the one benefit that
competitive games have over story is
that like there's a clear start and end
to a game you know what I mean like like
if you play like Hearthstone you know
you could play like two three games 20
20 30 minutes yeah you can get out
you'll get games over you can you have
that you have that window of like do I
start another game or do I just go back
to work yeah let's go do something else
right yeah and I think that's the one
thing that at least like like Alden ring
it's like dude it's like never like
there's never a break like it's always
go go story the world and so I kind of
like competitive games in that sense
where like sometimes I will boot up just
play two games with OverWatch go back to
work like it's a yeah
yeah if I have lunch and I eat my lunch
in 10 minutes but I I I I believe that I
should probably take at least a 30
minute break doing stuff it's like okay
well now I'll um you know I'll play two
games if I've ever watched then I'll go
back to work or something or I'll play
one game of TFT yeah or I'll you know
play a game of hearthstone yeah
that kind of mentality I like that there
are clear start and stop times right and
it's very much up to you if you want to
see see one one thing one thing I
realized because after coming back one
tour there was this like week two one
week or two week period where I I guess
like I had to like re-acclimate to the
normal work schedule again after I was
right back in it you're right back right
back two days [ __ ] like four like
four or five weeks until I was like I am
I need to just like not be in front of
an audience or for a while I just be in
my own Zone I need to like I've touched
too much grass recently and it's like
I'm like I need to not touch grass for a
while yeah and I just like I just had
like a like a week-long period where I
just did nothing but just like catch up
on my anime and just play games and I'll
and go on dates with Sydney and spend
like some quality time and I was like
[ __ ] this is so nice and I've missed
okay I've missed I I miss this feeling
of remember when you're in school right
and it was like it was like a school
holiday and so you had like three months
or something so you just you just spend
a whole week playing nothing but video
games and watching anime and you had no
pressure to do anything because you knew
that the school year didn't start for
like another two three weeks or
something like that
that that to me is like such a magical
feeling that I'd forgotten about because
being self-employed you always think you
can be doing something right you you you
you can be working towards something
right there is no mental reset of
school starts in three weeks therefore I
have three weeks to allow myself to do
nothing I believe what you discovered
was the feeling of retirement
wants to retire that just sounds like oh
you're like oh the retired life is kind
of nice I don't have to think about
doing work it's always aggressive so
it's green on the other side right if
you were tired after a few months of
taking it easy you'd probably be like
so what I'm talking about isn't
retirement and what I'm talking about is
balance actually I know yeah yeah no I
get that yeah because the idea of having
like three weeks off of doing nothing on
the and the same kind of three weeks off
is a bit too long but okay would you
feel bad okay would you feel bad if you
like now if you just took a week off
right took a week off from work and just
played video games oh yeah gotcha yeah
why because I'm not at that I'm not at
that State mentally right now where I
can do that and feel comfortable right
it's like I'm I'm kind of at this point
where I like taking breaks in between
work days yeah I'm like a break work day
break work day kind of mentality I I
don't like just doing like the full like
work for one week and then you can take
a break for one week yeah we're
extremely uh Lucky in a way where we can
we actually have a choice yes of course
we can decide hey I want to take a week
off how busy we are it's completely
optimized yeah I think I think a lot of
people don't have that choice um and I
think just being the ability to take a
week off is like I don't know even in
that itself is like that is kind of
fulfilling in a weird way where it's
like even though I'm not going to take a
week off knowing I can kind of helps me
it keeps me motivated in a weird way I'm
grinding now so I can retire faster yeah
it's kind of like it's like okay I'm I'm
I've worked really hard on on all this
YouTube stuff and of course we're all
very lucky yeah extremely lucky right um
but we also we also I think we work our
asses off yeah um and I I think knowing
that hey if I want to take a week off I
want to take two weeks off I have the
ability and we've worked to the point
where we have that option I think okay
that enough is like very fulfilling yeah
I don't necessarily need to take them
off yeah yeah because like guaranteed
there are people watching this that will
just take a week off just to [ __ ] do
nothing right and I think a lot of
people don't like they get the week off
it's like this is your week off now yeah
because that's like abnormal and all the
more power to them you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah do it [ __ ] do it yeah and
I'm just like because like for me for
example the reason I said play video
games is because
I like I think out of like the three of
us I probably game the least yeah
probably yeah probably yeah yeah and
part of the reason for that is because
like mentally I hate going into a video
game I hate gaming if I know that I
gotta stop after a certain point I love
going into a video game knowing I will
stop when I want to stop but if I go if
I ghost if I start over you can't sit
down and be like all right I play this
game for three hours and then I turn it
off no matter what and start working
yeah yeah I can't I can't be like I need
to be somewhere in two three hours so I
only have two three hours to play this
game even even just even just knowing
that I'm like I'm not gonna start the
video game because if I'm really really
into a game I want to play until I I
want to stop playing
I kind of get that feeling yeah but the
fact that even if you're like three
hours three that's a long time three
hours well in jrpg world it is when when
I'm into a game like I was playing God
of War for like five hours minimum at a
point just because I was so [ __ ]
invested right but like I I love that
feeling of like me like God damn I gotta
go I'm gonna do something and then the
whole time you're doing this something
you're like I can't wait to get back to
the game dude that's gonna be you like
that I love that for me that's how I
know I've got a banger yeah because I
hate that because for me like I can't
focus on the thing I'm doing because I'm
just thinking about the video because
that's like the difference in like like
the skill diff
I wonder if that's like an ADHD thing
well like I I'm fine with that like that
feeling is fine I'm content with it
maybe it's I don't know like I I'm just
curious I mean I don't know I just like
I just love the feeling I think this is
with all media for me I just love the
feeling of like being completely
absorbed into something I do [ __ ]
hate it if I have to stop watching
something on like Netflix yeah halfway
through like an episode yeah that pisses
me off because I'm like can we at least
stop it like a checkpoint yeah like if
like the documentary is like a 40 minute
long three apps or something and I've
stopped 30 minutes in I'm like well
that's the same with like a jrpg for me
it's like I'd rather instead of stopping
at like the save points right no but
like there's there's save points in a
lot of games and then there are like
story transitions right like I would
much rather I hate stopping at like save
points before something big in this part
of the story is about to happen yeah I'd
rather just power through if I if the
time lets me to just power through and
get to that point where the story then
takes a turn goes in a different
direction I'm like okay that's a good
place it's like it's like you know if
you're reading a book and you finish
like halfway through a chapter versus
just powering through and just finishing
the chapter no I agree I think that like
yeah that's obviously better
um but with the game sometimes those
things are so few involved between you
yeah it depends on the ones everywhere
else because you can just say it depends
on yeah for sure yeah modern games have
just auto save yeah some reason for some
reason jfpgs haven't figured that out
yet no yeah it's so weird because I'm
playing trails and it doesn't auto save
yeah sure I'm so [ __ ] stupid so
sometimes I die in a [ __ ] fight or
something or or yeah sometimes I die in
a fight I'm like [ __ ] when did I last
save wait when did I last have to think
about saving before boss fight doesn't
just automatically do this for me it's
been a while back in my day I saved
three times just to be sure I'm like did
I say it but did I actually say it no
did I really say it okay here's the real
question if you manually save do you
just have one save file that you
overwrite every time hell no or do you
have like [ __ ] 10 million dollars are
you are you a single saver or you're a
Multiverse I'm a multi-file sailor for
sure I'm I'm I don't know 50 50. 50 50.
I'm just like I'm like every new
checkpoint I go to the new file and then
if I run out of files yeah but then if I
run out of files like say you know it's
like 10 or 20 files if I run out of
files I go back and overwrite the first
yeah because you're never gonna go back
to their save files no you're not but
it's just it's comfortable it's
something to know that you could you you
could if you wanted to you know you
never going to okay because I was I was
a singer I was you know I was a single
file save Andy for like a while yeah and
then I played Sona 5. yeah and then I'm
like no no no no no no no
wait my choices have consequence and you
only have a certain amount of time you
can spend with people okay this this
requires multiple saves I need to make
sure I made the right choice yeah yeah
did I go back to any of those savings
absolutely
I'm shuffling with someone else on that
day yeah I don't know it's it's
certainly with Persona 5 I actually use
those multiple safe files because I
actually wanted to like go through all
the routes and I was like I'm not
playing through the first 15 hours again
just again
you've completed it like three times I
have yes
but the first couple of times I was just
like no let's go back to the save file
and then I'm like that's not the same
I'll just start a new file what about
you Connor is there any goals at all
aside from just make cool stuff I don't
know something specific and rank irony
yeah I think uh I don't know in my mind
Big Goal big lofty goals when we get the
start of the year yeah I just sort of
setting yourself up for disappointment a
lot of the times I find I think some
people sorry it's not like I was a
[ __ ] from vomiting I think some
people they help and some people they're
detrimental I'm sure you've known many
people who have been like I'm gonna do
this and like they'd never ever do
anything they ever say ever I'm sure you
know people of course okay okay let let
me let me rephrase the question sure
sure is there anything you're excited to
do yeah excited about in 2023 yeah yeah
I sometimes I don't want to say exactly
yeah okay
there's a few things I really want to do
there's a there's a Direction I want to
go with maybe some live stuff that I
really want to try and make happen get
off the ground
um I think I just wanna I'm always
looking to evolve my content because
that's how I get like personal
fulfillment uh making something cool and
having a great time doing it where yeah
everyone wins like the viewer the higher
have a good time people working on it
have a great time yeah that's that's
what I you know really really uh Chase
um and I think gaming for me is like a
great relax and it's something I always
always loved my entire life and if I can
find a good game that I love and I don't
feel bad about playing that's a win too
it's it's like I'm looking for little
wins all across the board right
now the small dogs yeah I actually wanna
you know I also want to spend more time
with family this year oh yeah I do to
curve it I really get spent a lot of
time with them even this year I've only
got some of them like once yeah in the
entire year like one day
um and so yeah
one day yeah I've only seen them one day
yeah um because of I covered [ __ ] that
happened yeah and you know I really want
to spend more time with them um I also
want to just I really want to just
miscellaneously get good good at weird
stuff I really want to get a motorcycle
license for no reason
not when I go and spend time my family
and this is my brain maxing right yeah
I'm like I'm like oh well sometimes like
I you know during the day they're doing
their own thing and I'm doing my own
thing and then we just kind of we all
hang out in the evenings and we all yeah
have that family time and I realized oh
I probably just go back do this like
four five day motorcycle course and
during the day and then hang out with
them in the evening I was like oh that
sounds awesome
I want to do that and I'm like oh this
makes sense because I'd want to do it in
the UK as well yeah right I'm like oh I
could kill two birds with one stone I
don't know why I want to get a I have no
desire to actually like ride motorcycles
often I'm like that would just be cool
to have and also I actually would like
to ride some mopeds in Japan and other
motorcycles yeah I have thought about
getting a moped license in Japan just be
like it'd be nice to just like you know
if I had like a couple of hours free
just jump on them open just go somewhere
yeah like weak mopeds you can um I think
you don't need any particular training
for in Japan I can't remember you okay
so something I know I looked into this
if in Japan if you want to get like if
you want to ride like those not a
motorcycle motorcycle you have to go to
like an actual yeah yeah but like the
actual like scooters you can just all
you have to do is just like go to a
place uh and you can just take an online
test I think because the the depends on
the CC of the vehicle how powerful and
you can just take an online test for
like 50 bucks or something and if you
pass you get the license immediately
because you also really want to do more
big things as well and I thought oh it
could be really cool if we had like you
know we did some kind of content that
evolved around modes of transport and if
I could ride any type of motorcycles
yeah okay cool well this feels weird I'm
like isn't that sick that you can just
get you can only acquire this like
skills I think it's awesome it's
collecting the chaos emeralds
particularly I don't particularly like
like there could not be a more gamer way
to say it
a lot of the times people have don't
have the time don't have the money they
don't have the the need to want to learn
some of these more odd skills yeah or
not common skills I just thought oh well
you know an opposition we're extremely
lucky and I feel like I should learn
just can't constantly be trying to learn
new skills that it can be useful I feel
like if I it's a five days of my life
and then I can ride motorcycles the rest
of my life that's pretty [ __ ] sick
yeah yeah like that'd be kind of nice
like and I thought about stuff like that
and I'm like oh man would be cool to be
able to drive a truck I don't even know
I want to drive a truck but I'm like
that'd be sick to be able to do just to
say you can could you imagine it I'm
like boys Boss by the way I'll drive it
like that'd be awesome like I just it's
like that one it's like that one person
you know that just has every type of
license yeah you don't need every type
of life I have no desire for this is it
weird that I want to do it I think so
but I also think that like it's it's
like a pilot's license as well that's
well that's that's way more work that's
not like if it's something you could do
within x amount of days I'm like oh yeah
[ __ ] it let's do it like why not Conor's
like Conor's like Min maxing skill trees
it's like yeah what's the what's the
most skills I can acquire for the least
amount no right like there's so many
things out there that are like very like
not that hard to kind of be able to do
and then you know you you can do them
for life it's like becoming fluid in
Japanese no that's that's like years of
work becoming a motorcycle driver yeah
two Daisy I started with learning
I love those the idea that you can do
these like short courses or short things
and then you you walk out with a
lifetime skill yeah yeah it's really
cool absolutely and if you have the time
and the ability and the money to be able
to do it all right sure like because you
can you can do courses and like it
depends on what type of license you want
but you can do like three to five days
yeah no I I definitely want to do more
then you can transfer to Japan yeah yeah
for sure for sick I want to ride a
Harley that'd be so [ __ ] awesome
Holly's associate I saw these dudes in
Japan when we were cycling on Hokkaido
they had like they were like uh
motorcycling across Hokkaido they look
so [ __ ] fun it looks so cool I think
it's fun because you're doing it with
the boys right yeah there's like two of
them doing it man I was hyped but then
if you have x a certain license like the
best one you can have people ride with
you oh yeah yeah that would be [ __ ]
cool like Joey hop on the back let's go
by the way I did three days of
motorcycle training
yeah you know I just thought that that's
really cool that'd be fun no I
understand I I I and I wanna I really
want to try and learn more of these like
skills that are that are very like quick
to acquire but a lifetime uh you know
yeah no I I totally agree with that
sentiment like you know again like
during the pandemic especially I was at
that point where I'm like what are like
some things that I could easily learn at
home that are gonna be completely
useless to me but it's just cool to say
that I can do it and like learning how
to solve a Rubik's Cube was like one of
them it's like it's not gonna [ __ ]
get here everyone have that pandemic
skill yeah it's like it's not going to
get me a job but you know it's it's a
cool bar trick now that I can do so [ __ ]
it you know whatever yeah
bring me a Roots
yeah I think that would be like just
awesome and I I'm always wanting to
improve myself uh and learn new skills
and I think you know why not like and I
don't know why I decided I was like I
kind of want to learn motorcycle first
that feels very achievable very easy
well not easy very very doable and also
I get to see my family at the same time
so I was like all right that sounds like
a Google for sure yeah it'd be fun yeah
we could do like car versus train bus
motorcycles we'll do that with that
that's right this is fun think about the
content as well we have so much content
out of this sure always the content
brain with you man no it's both it's all
it's like if you can if the Venn diagram
it fits everything that's why am I not
doing it yeah yeah like you know what I
mean no I guess that's awesome I get it
yeah no I I I totally understand and I
totally understand that that's just the
way up
you're like I I hate this idea that
everything in [ __ ] life you need to
be super goddamn passionate about and
that like oh you have a good enough
reason to do something [ __ ] off maybe I
just wanted to [ __ ] do it on the way
maybe I just want to do it maybe I'd
rather try it like yeah I don't know if
I like motorcycles I was never in a
family that did motorcycles I don't
[ __ ] know well I want to try it let
me [ __ ] get that always has to be a
first yeah like that I just I hate this
notion that you have to have a good
enough reason to do anything for fun
things oh oh you've never shown
interested in shuffling before why are
you surfing it's like [ __ ] off maybe I
just want to try it yeah what's uh
what's like the weirdest thing that you
like picked up or learned before just
like randomly
has there ever been anything like an
activity like a skill interpretive
damage have you actually I used to break
down so I was like 12 and I [ __ ] I'm
still [ __ ] because everyone as a kid
they they tried this like one weird
thing like every like everyone has this
one weird thing whether they're a kid or
an adult or something they and they've
tried something you know a weird
activity that they just never picked up
again for example because they grew up
or they ran out of time or something
like that so like for example I remember
in like in like University I did a year
of like ballroom and Latin America
dancing really yeah I was I I think like
the only reason I stopped was because
third year of unit I know I did two
years ago like third year of University
had no time to do it no I I think back
and I was like [ __ ] that was fun as hell
man I did uh I did Karate for three
months karate watching those roots uh
what's the one above white brown brown
yeah I did Karate as a kid as well I got
to Brown
and then and then the training just got
like it just went like 10 levels
yeah because I noticed I noticed with a
lot of these activities right with
karate or something you know it's it's
easy to like get into you know you you
have you hit a certain point maybe where
it's like brown belt where he's just
like I'm only casually doing this one
activity and then you will always hit
that wall where if you want to make
progress It's just like oh the time
investment Sally just jumps up tenfold
now I have to be dedicated yeah yeah
yeah yeah it goes from like being just a
casual fun activity to like a proper
hobby you know what I mean there's so
many hobbies like that like especially
when I was like in high school and [ __ ]
there was just so many things like that
where I'm like yo give it a go and then
I would get to the point where I'm like
okay I'm enjoying this and then that the
like I taught myself how to play flute
just randomly I never had an interest in
the instrument and I'm just like yo just
see if I can learn it and then I go
pretty good and then yeah and then I hit
that wall where it's like oh now I have
to start learning these like new [ __ ] I
I a lot of the times when you you know
you become an adult and you're working
you have a lot of time people just stop
learning stuff yeah and I find that
because they're content with where they
are right yeah and people also at least
this happened a lot in the UK people
would like make fun of you if you
started learning something new
um you know as an adult because they're
like because they were self-conscious
that they weren't really trying to
improve themselves or learn new skills
yeah and I hate that so [ __ ] much no
it's just you know again I think it's
not it's not even doing that I feel like
you got like if you did some in the UK
at least with my experience as an adult
if you did something that was just
outside of the circle of like what's
normal yeah or just outside of what they
perceive you as you know your character
then you would you know you would be
called out as being like why are you
doing this [ __ ] oh it's just it's a
phase it's a phase yeah Australia was
the exact same yeah like why are you
trying reach Japan it's so far away yeah
yeah yeah that's right and I I feel like
it's the same thing with like learning
as well because a lot of adults I feel
like why there's this big stigma around
oh you learn languages for example
better when you're a kid or you just
learn better when you're a kid I think
that's like complete [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just that number one you just run
out of time to like learn things because
learning takes time you know learning a
new skill takes time but I feel like you
are just as capable as an adult learning
new things new skills whenever you want
to but the problem is it's just harder
to fit around your adult schedule yeah
that's that's saying of like oh you
can't teach an old dog new tricks that's
[ __ ] yeah you absolutely can it's
just a matter of are you willing to give
it a go to begin with because if you're
not then yeah of course you're not going
to be a lot of um there's a lot of
studies been done that like learning
skills and particularly language uh
later on in life is really beneficial to
um like stopping any kind of stopping
but like I I think it was like
particularly language if you learn
language later on life you were it would
reduce the risk of getting like
Alzheimer's and stuff like that yeah
because it was it was unlocking like a
certain part of the brain that you had
well you're keeping your brain active
basically like learning stuff and doing
that is very healthy
um whether it be just a Rubik's Cube or
learning a like flying a plane like yeah
all this stuff is great or even simple
stuff like you know uh playing chess or
like Mahjong and like like board games
that require a lot of like brain power
and thinking it's like yeah that's the
reason why so many like older people
play it it's because they're keeping
their brains active and healthy yeah and
it's like that's super important at a
certain age obviously not at our age yet
but eventually we'll get to a point
hopefully if we survive that long where
you know we'll need activities like that
and we'll need to be curious enough to
be like all right what's something I can
do you know what's what's a new thing I
can learn what's something I can improve
on yeah because if you're just content
with the [ __ ] that you have over the 60
70 years that you've lived then you're
just gonna end up being like well
kind of [ __ ] bored now uh not much to
do brain empty I do want to be able to
drive every vehicle yeah I don't know
why all right all right what about my
James Bond moment where I gotta I gotta
steal every vehicle they get away you
know what I mean like I don't know I
just really like the idea of being able
to it would be cool drive a boat fly a
plane yeah [ __ ] a motorcycle like do
all this cool [ __ ] I don't know why for
no particular you never have to worry
about no reason
yeah hypothetical question all right
we're not automatically hypothetical
question all right we're not on the
grinds anymore we're in retirement age
I'm in retirement age okay you have all
the free time in the world and you can
do anything you want what are you doing
I'll probably get a pilot license I
really want to [ __ ] fly a plane I
would travel to as many countries as I
can like just travel and then I'll just
jump the world
I myself
it's like TSA [ __ ] please yeah this is
your captain speaking to me let's go
I think I would start learning and
picking up more musical instruments I
really like I really you can do that now
I could I just like
I miss playing the guitar I think I I
could easily let him out with you dude I
I miss I miss playing it but like you
can learn as well
if there's one musical instrument that
I've always wanted to play and my
probably my favorite musical instrument
is probably the piano okay
you instantly get 10 times sexier you do
I just want to get to the point where
all I have to do is
that's all it's like that's the only
thing I can play piano has a certain
Elegance too yeah there's just something
like that just like mesmerizing about
seeing someone God's Asian side of the
show
I don't know something about hearing
like some something about hearing like
someone who's just really good at the
time there's just something that just
moves me in a way that no other like
instrument can and every other
instrument has saxophone in your face
although if I have a sexism on my face
that's a different car you like feeling
bro I'm like bricks
there's a big difference between chakra
opening and breakdown I just like every
time I talk to Kevin I remember like
when Kevin uh when I when I found out
Kevin was composing for like uh rising
of The Shield hero yeah and like I've
heard isekai soundtracks before right
and I was like let's see how Kevin let's
see what Kevin would do right and like
you know I watched the first few
episodes and it's just like kind of like
the generic kind of fancy things but I
like out of nowhere and it's one scene
he just breaks out the [ __ ] saxophone
I'm like [ __ ] hell Kevin yo I didn't
need to be breaked up in an Easter car
man Kevin please stop man holy [ __ ]
that's not the time now is not the time
Kevin you're a [ __ ] genius by the way
that saxophone
yeah I definitely would want to learn
more instruments as well yeah yeah again
it's like no there's no reason why
there's no deeper [ __ ] love it's just
I just I just want to give it a go
something in my head wants me to do that
I don't know I want to be like that cool
dad or that cool Uncle who's just like
yeah what do you want to do there's a
lot of cool things I can show you yeah
yeah and that's why I totally get the
wanting to have every like driving
license
I might use it once in my life like yeah
I have a forklift license no because
like
yourself
yeah I gotta turn up to the Amazon
warehouse yeah boys boys I can do that
for you my time has come boys step out
of the way I learned how to drive this
thing 30 years ago yeah because I have
an uncle that does have a pilot's
license uh yeah that's a long time to
get it's not it's expensive
you gotta have money yeah yeah and time
and yeah because uh I think he he lives
he lives in Australia and apparently
like that
yeah yeah exactly so it's quite easy to
find a place to get your partner's
license still takes a [ __ ] ton of time
oh yeah there's so much exams and stuff
as well like I'm [ __ ] jealous man
because my my nephew is also like in the
process of getting his his pilot's
license and he's [ __ ] 18 I'm like
[ __ ] you man how'd you get to be so cool
when you're 18. [ __ ] you that is such a
bragging rate as well at 18 yeah it's
like yeah I can fly a plane yeah yeah I
remember when we were I was in the
University one time and this guy he's on
my course his dad uh was a like a
recreational pilot just for fun yeah you
did engineering or something and um his
dad would you know sort of drive from
North Wales also South Wales to like
North England it was like four five six
hours yeah depending on where you go and
he was just like oh yeah no no my dad's
gonna pick me up at the local airport
like it's a tiny little strip and fly
him back can you believe that I was like
God
this is so cool
I like 40 30 minutes I'm like that's
[ __ ] up the only thing colder than
that is like you get to [ __ ] skip all
this traffic you no [ __ ] luggage fees
like you you know you just get to
[ __ ] go on the [ __ ] tarmac the
only thing just as cool as that is like
a helicopter license dude
yeah that would be epic yeah my dad's
coming to pick me up and they're like
all the time
it's like son where are you
[ __ ] bring the chopper out God I
don't know how it works I know that
I think helicopters are way more
expensive I think yeah to get the
license
to have a helicopter oh to have a house
yeah I'm sure really then a plane I
guess maybe they're not as common right
um yeah I mean like National planes are
I mean obviously sort of expensive I
think also just for my engineering
course I remember this they they the way
that planes and airplanes are like um I
need to fact check this guy
um I think like a plane it's con you
know how like a car is Miles right yeah
we judge a car by like it's Ten Thousand
Miles yeah a plane is like the moment it
like is is done it starts ticking like
how how long it's allowed to like
operate without that stuff but I think a
helicopter is similar to uh to cars I
can't remember or it's miles there's
something something different about it I
remember the planes haven't used by date
yeah the planes literally have like a
the moment they're done they start
ticking on like okay you have to
maintenance them every x amount of
months or they're not allowed to fly
right I mean that makes sense I would
hope so
that's why that's why you know you lose
a lot of money when the plane is just
sitting there yeah
if you use a plane every single moment
it's like possible in the air it like
the way that it's checked and the way
that service is no different to if that
plane has been in a hangar with no use
at all right in terms of like how it's
cared for it needs to be like the same
kind of service
um so that's why a lot of the times when
the headlines like go go go go yeah use
it as much as you can because it's arena
this is [ __ ] expensive to keep it
playing yeah what about like uh what
about like a boat license I want a boat
license that's way more like a sailor's
license or uh you can sell you can sell
about you know like a yacht license yeah
a lot yeah well it's it's like a powered
yeah so after a certain size I think
yeah I can't remember what it is I would
definitely go fishing more yeah [ __ ] man
my question to me and both questions are
very achievable yeah I don't yeah I
wonder if they transfer from like other
countries to Japan I don't know if they
do I know for sure because that'd be
hype that would be hard to get my boat
license in the UK be like hide your hand
give me the yard because basically tldr
if you if you come from a foreign
country get your licenses in that
foreign country and then transfer them
to Japan because it sucks in Japan yeah
and it's funnily enough a lot of license
are transferable you know except for
Americans
so let's do an exams yeah you have to do
it you can transfer it you have to do an
exam and a test I'll shoot your test
still oh wow the test only in Japanese
which [ __ ] sucks ripperonis I think
boys this year
trash days has been a resounding success
they always say yeah oh yeah absolutely
yeah
um it's been like this year has been the
busiest year of my life not just
obviously saying that [ __ ] every year
though I mean we've been saying this for
a month yeah she's gonna be crazy yeah
well I mean we knew but like I just feel
like with our careers it's just every
year it's just one upping itself in
terms of business yeah I think 2023 is
going to be uh honestly I'm saying right
now I don't I don't think next year is
going to be as busy and I'm fine with
that you know I think I don't think so I
think it's pretty good I think it's
gonna be just as busy oh no man you you
haven't you haven't tried planning a
wedding Oh Yeah from a different country
on top of going I guess that's true and
touring conventions and everything like
that you were definitely twice as busy
as oh yeah yes yeah I remember I
remember it was just like the moment it
hit me was the moment where I was just
like
I felt like I I just I never thought I'd
get to a point where I would just fly
back to Japan for 10 days just to film
like trash days episodes then fly back
to another country to go plan my wedding
again and then fly back to like go fly
America like the week after I'd finished
my wedding that's right to go film more
trash days and film or specials I was
like yeah that that uh that schedule now
that I think back to when I'm like how
how the [ __ ] did we do that yeah yeah it
was intense yeah it was like it was a
bit too intense I I feel like next year
is still going to be
it's still gonna be intense I'm almost
saying it's not going to be like a walk
in the park or and everything like that
but I feel like this year was kind of
pushing it like it's pushing it to its
limit it's not until like you know
friends and stuff like that ask me about
like the tour and stuff like that and
like what we've been doing this year
like you know going to the US and going
to the UK Australia all that and then
them going man that sounds [ __ ]
insane like how did you do it it's not
until someone says that where I'm just
like yeah it was kind of insane a lot of
planning a lot of planning yeah good
planning can prepare for anything also I
realized that like since we went to
America the first time this year some
people I who I used to hang out with you
know semi often I'm like I haven't seen
them in like six months and they live in
the same country as them no yeah oh yeah
yeah wow that's a long time yes it's
it's it's weird because when you're in
like when you plan everything beforehand
you don't really when you know
something's coming up you don't you
don't really have the mental time to
like switch off to like really reflect
on it and being like wow I'm doing a lot
because in the moment moment you're like
yeah I just got this next thing I can't
think about I'm doing a lot because I I
need to think about the next thing I'm
doing yeah and it's only it's only now
that everything's stopped I'm like [ __ ]
I did a lot that was difficult let's
make it still a lot but manageable yeah
for sure which I think next year is
going to be I have like I'll not we have
like trash taste projects that we got
planned for next year and I have like
some personal projects I'm sure we all
have personal projects oh boy yeah oh
yeah oh boy oh yeah
but I am if I'm excited to work my
personal projects because this year has
been a lot of trash taste projects
um and I'm like I'm like let's do trash
taste and personal stuff as well and
it's gonna be it's gonna be nice it's
gonna be nice
W big boys maxing the dog
but uh yeah I guess uh give you guys as
well for watching this for another year
yeah uh you know there's been some
episodes you guys like somebody didn't
like as much but ultimately you stuck
around and we appreciate that yeah if
you just subscribe today or you
subscribed you know two and a half years
ago when we started we appreciate you um
hey but you know who else we appreciate
our patrons these guys you guys stuck
around these guys yeah those are these
are the real ones man yeah well uh yeah
if you uh would like to support the show
for the next year 2023 trash days then
uh make sure to go over to our patreon
patreon.com trash days also follow us on
Twitter Sinister memes on the subreddit
if I had our face listen to us on
Spotify and uh Happy New Year everyone
happy New Year yeah see you guys in 2023
all right bye
[Music]